le tabac pour beaucoup c'est le
compagnon de tous les jours apprécié ou
supporter de toute façon ces ronds de
fumée sont familiers mais la culture
même de cette plante l'est beaucoup
moins
ici nous sommes à j 10 dans le loiret ce
que vous découvrez sont des plants de
tabac couronnées de fleurs spectacle
inattendu si l'on sait que cette plante
en est généralement dépourvus aussi
avons nous demandé à monsieur planer
inspecteur à la production des tabacs le
pourquoi de ce mode de culture pour le
moins inhabituel
ces plans sont originaux en ce sens que
l'on vous constatez qu on a pas estimé
la plante chez monsieur le comte poussée
qui lui pratiquer la culture du tabac
non et 6 mai pour la production de tabac
pauvres en nicotine
alors c'est une peau une production très
particulière puisque dans le département
elle n'intéresse que 24 planteurs pour
une dizaine d'hectares seulement c'est
un peu si vous voulez un galop d'essai
du reste c'est susceptible d'être
étendue dans l'avenir dans un avenir
relativement proche
et est-ce que techniquement vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce mode de plantation
comment vous y prenez-vous pour obtenir
un tabac faible en nicotine
alors on laisse développer comme vous le
voyez la fleur alors que normalement on
estime la plante c'est à dire on les
têtes à une certaine hauteur qui
correspond au niveau de la feuille que
l'on veut conserver ont conservé la
toute la plante mais on traite
l'inflorescence avec un produit que l'on
appelle nos shoots t et en pulvérisation
avec un appareil alors dans le cas de
monsieur le comte
ce traitement a été fait pied par pied
mais il existe des possibilités de
traitement mécanique avec des rampes à
grand débit obtenir du tabac taux de
nicotine moindres est une chose reste à
savoir dans quelles proportions la
dangereuse substance se trouve être
réduite
alors ici à ma droite
nous avons des tabacs qui sont traités
de façon traditionnelle c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont et 6 mai et qui en
conséquence ont un taux de nicotine nous
doivent avoir un taux de nicotine qui
tournera autour de 1 5 à 1 à 2% alors
qu'ici avec le nom des six mais nous
espérons descendre à un taux de nicotine
beaucoup plus bas de l'ordre de 1 à 1,2
pour cent voilà après cette
démonstration de culture comparez vous
serez sans doute reconnaître à l'avenir
les deux variétés de plants de tabac
ajoutons que si cette année la récolte
de tabac en fleurs n'en est encore qu'au
stade expérimental dans le loiret il
semble bien qu'elle soit promise à
extension dans un proche avenir